la maladie des homosexuels celle que
l'on a découvert il y a un an et demi
aux états unis et qui fait de véritables
ravages des ravages mortels et bien
cette maladie atteint maintenant
l'europe les responsables de la santé en
france et en europe se sont réunis hier
à paris alors un nivellement quelles
mesures ont ils décidé entre d'autres en
d'autres termes que faut-il faire
la seule mesure que l'on puisse prendre
en l'état actuel des connaissances sur
cette maladie
c'est l'information du public et cette
information va être fait une large
échelle dont tous les centres de
transfusion sanguine de france et
d'europe
cette maladie dite des homosexuels et
appeler plus scientifiquement le
syndrome immuno déficitaire acquis en
abrégé le siba c'est à dire un
affaiblissement de nos défenses
immunitaires
elle est due vraisemblablement un virus
sur 3000 cas recensés dans le monde 2000
sont marc la plupart aux états unis mais
l'europe n'est pas épargnée 200 cas en
allemagne 70 au danemark 49 en france
maladie mortelle dans tous les cas
puisque aucun traitement n'existe
jusqu'à maintenant
la transmission d'abord une transmission
interhumaine probablement par un virus
qu'on ignore pour l'instant dont on ne
sait pas reconnaître les caractères et
donc on ne sait pas dépister mais qui
est abrité dans certains réservoir
humain que l'on connaît bien déjà depuis
de longues années qu'ils sont et ce sont
les réservoirs humain où on appris à
connaître l'hépatite virale l'hépatite
virale b notamment et qui sont un lait
troc et tillous de la drogue par voie
intraveineuse de les homosexuels mais
les homosexuels actifs et notamment les
bisexuels partenaires multiples 3 les
sujets originaire de haïti
et on commence à penser qu'il ya aussi
des sujets originaires d'afrique noire
notamment au zaïre
ce sont là les grands nous réservoir du
virus à partir desquels la maladie va se
propager et par voie inter humaine il
n'ya pas donc lieu d'affoler les
populations qui viennent donner leur
sang ou qui reçoivent le sens qu'il faut
pas de panique ni au niveau du donneur
car les donneurs français
n'appartiennent pas aux catégories de
laïcité je parlais tout à l'heure les
normes sexuelles peut-être mais voilà
pourquoi il faut les informer
il faut les informer qu'il faut
s'informer et les décisions que nous
avons prises en comité consultatif au
ministère tout récemment ont pour but de
le voir avec ces personnes comment on
peut les informer par quelle voie il y a
fort heureusement des moyens et les gens
du jour nos illusions des réunions ils
ont des radios et à la radio gay à paris
je pense qu'on veut passer information
là dessus car c'est dans leur intérêt
plus encore que dans l'intérêt de tout
le monde mais leurs propres intérêts et
l'art du bien connaître de bien savoir
qu'ils ont des risques de cette maladie